[Music]
Curtains to a slide for reasons for
in front
many read wales so juncker follows why
still there because otherwise in
Germany extremely
[Music]
where we met him was
get roads like most
our boys street boys
[Music]
[Applause]
the first were Turkish and Arab
and Kurdish people so we have him
then at that time just taken the hand
and introduced them to this hip hop scene
and helped them do that
he had his stuff from Kreuzberg
he support sport and we wanted
currently from this criminal railways
At this time was a trip hop
such a very good story resistant
families thereby also for
islam converts there is a contact
with these with some people here
Do not come a couple of funny pseudo
have learned and in the moment
then we also get rid of them
we pulled him in the corner
drawn to the computer and
then he has us for that, too
foreigner or professional 700 german
security group europe
For one thing I think that has a lot
to do that with your religion
not really complete learning like that
that equipped with half knowledge
simply from any people
be caught and then
be brainwashed here too
in the migrants cats in europe the on
the search for identity where you just what
to give them an inner stability
especially at a young age one tends
now ask about extremities
although that does not even come somehow
0 1 percent of muslims worldwide
will make and then stop
to be representative at one go and us
Everyone has to shit us for this
justify so and discredit it
all so muslim the community
just destroyed